-Here with the TV debut
of his song
"Standing Next to You"
from his new album "Golden,"
give it up for Jungkook!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Standing next to you ♪
♪ Play me slow ♪
♪ Push up on this funk
and give me miracles ♪
-♪ Let ya body know ♪
-♪ Make it known ♪
♪ How we left and right
is somethin' we control ♪
-♪ You already know ♪
♪ You know that all night long,
we rock to this ♪
-♪ Screamin',
I testify this lovin' ♪
-♪ All night long,
we flock to this ♪
-♪ Screamin', I testify that ♪
♪ We'll survive
the test of time ♪
♪ They can't deny our love ♪
♪ They can't divide us ♪
♪ We'll survive
the test of time ♪
♪ I promise I'll be right here ♪
-♪ Standing next to you ♪
♪ Standing in the fire
next to you, oh ♪
-♪ You know it's deeper
than the rain ♪
♪ It's deeper than the pain ♪
♪ When it's deep like DNA ♪
♪ Somethin' they can't take
away, ayy ♪
♪ Take-take-take-take-take-take
off ♪
♪♪
-♪ Standing next to you ♪
♪ Standing next to you ♪
♪ Standing
next to you ♪
♪♪
♪ Afterglow ♪
-♪ Leave ya body golden
like the sun and the moon ♪
-♪ You already know ♪
♪ You know that all night long ♪
-Hey.
-♪ We rock to this ♪
-♪ Oh ♪
-♪ Screamin',
I testify this lovin' ♪
-♪ All night long,
we flock to this ♪
♪ All night long ♪
-♪ Screamin', I testify that ♪
♪ We'll survive
the test of time ♪
♪ They can't deny our love ♪
♪ They can't divide us ♪
♪ We'll survive
the test of time ♪
-Hey.
-♪ I swear that
I'll be right here ♪
♪ Standing next to you ♪
-♪ Next to you ♪
♪ -Standing in the fire
next to you, oh ♪
-♪ Next to you ♪
♪ You know it's deeper
than the rain ♪
♪ It's deeper than the pain ♪
♪ When it's deep like DNA ♪
♪ Somethin' they can't take
away, ayy ♪
♪ Take-take-take-take-take-take
off ♪
♪♪
-♪ Standing next to you ♪
♪ Standing next
to you ♪
♪ Standing next to you ♪
♪ Standing next to you,
standing next to you ♪
♪ Standing next to you, standing
next to you ♪
♪ Hey ♪
♪ Standing next to you,
standing next to you ♪
♪ Standing next to you ♪
♪ Standing
next to you ♪
♪ Bass and drums ♪
♪♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ Whoo ♪
♪♪
-♪ Standing next to you ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]